the nexus
is being focused it's going down and fun
to us phoenix are your world champions
in 2020 league of legends changed
forever the old god of fallen that a new
era begins in the lpl after years of
denial
the second place was no longer good
enough the old kings of china
world champions were toppled by young
upstarts
knight has package jdg it's a numbers
advantage but top b sports
individual players but the old misses
from jacking up the pillar
comes in lines it up and kills zoom jack
in love with several that's a bit of
healing konami
slowed by the package again every single
time
they pulled off an unthinkable heist
and they're not done yet
[Music]
for years the old kings of chinese
league of legends
ruled the lpl you knew their names
royal edward gaming invictus gaming
and you knew their stars uzi clear love
rookie and when china conquered the
international stage
these rampaging kings were the ones who
hoisted the trophies
while the rest of the world cowered in
fear
first came invictus gaming who won
china's first world championship in 2018
earning respect from the world the lpl
has never won before
but that will change today the
groundless
are finally king and infect this gaming
are your 2018 world champions
then came fun plus phoenix the next year
and though they were less established
they were anything but rookies the nexus
is being focused
it's going down and fun plus phoenix
are your world champions the greatest
players in china had built
dynasties created legends they'd smashed
every adversary and in the end they held
league of legends greatest prize
but beneath the royalty there was a new
generation
young and hungry waiting for a chance to
prove themselves waiting for a chance to
steal
that prize everything changed in 2020
china's hungry young players ripped the
trophy right from under the nose of the
old kings
it was an incredible heist but every
great heist
needs a crew the first members of our
crew
well their story began in an internet
cafe
knight and yagao grew up together in
ping shang and when they fell in love
with league of legends they
started going to internet cafes the same
internet cafe
their duels in the mid lane were fierce
as the two young
up-and-coming players battled for the
title of the best mid and ping shang
as they grew older they faced off in new
cities new stages
and eventually in the lpl nightinya
gao's battle to be the best
never ended the stakes just got a lot
higher
so it'd be a lot more aggressive take
the straight lands into
by 2019 knight had finally gotten ahead
of yagao
people were starting to call him china's
next great mid-lane talent
but then invictus gaming brought them
both down
they jump on it immediately jackie love
takes the first the second goes over to
him as well
zooms late to the party they'll just
give it all
as ig run on in they say hey
it doesn't matter quadra
yes you know he gets the penta kill and
that'll be all
g-rode the cannon goes down at top e
sports around and it's 3v2
logan's away from his face i think ig
have done it yeah
nice the only one that needs to die on
this one and that's it knight has
fallen ig will earn their spot to defend
their championship
and take the third seed to represent
china
at europe during ig's miraculous run to
worlds 2019
they toppled both jdg and top in the
gauntlet
shattering knight and yagao's world's
dreams
so going into 2020 the prodigies from
ping chang
were ready for some revenge which brings
us to the next member of our crew
another prodigy who was looking to make
up for a brutal
2019 kenavi
as part of a controversial string of
business decisions by his former org
kanavi was loaned to chinese team jd
gaming on a contract that a korean
senator called
worse than slavery but as griffin
imploded in the wake of their
controversy
kanavi was freed he signed a new
contract with jd gaming in november
kenavi is such a such an exceptional
player for the fact that
he's willing to come into the lpl last
year on jdg on alone
and have such a good performance even in
a chaotic situation
and i think jdg are the team that have
allowed him to flourish
because how many other teams would their
laners be willing to say hey
we'll give up waves to let you invade
we'll give up waves
to go help and make sure you can get the
most out of what you want
and it's really been a kind of match
made in heaven with kenavi and jdg
definitely think it was the team's
commitment to play around him and this
is something that he did say in
interviews
when he resigned with jd gaming as a
free agent after
all the troubles in the off season jd
gaming did say that they were willing to
actually just reform the team around him
and i i think they stayed true to that
promise
but he's actually going to jump straight
in on top of this tristana and there's
the jump straight down on top of him the
teleport did come in cataclysm was
stolen but they have got garbage trying
to do as much damage as he possibly can
pyl is here but it's only really to try
and keep everybody away he's going to
try and find a damage but there's no one
there kramer just wasn't there on time
double kill for the silas and jdg taking
control
you gow as well getting basically the
one what is the damage
kanavi for jdg this is their way into
the top four
of the lpl bellows when she stops the
show
for what was that double kill now for
kenavi
wade can't do anything about it and
he'll fall as well
that's a triple on to the board
but
aggressive carry style jungling took jdg
to the top of the league in the spring
split
but he wasn't doing it alone in addition
to help from the rest of his incredible
team
he had yagao in his mid lane still
fighting to outdo his childhood rival
knight jdg are a team we've been calling
the smartest team in the lpl
you can see it all starts from the early
game that they're really good at playing
around their jungler kanavi it's all
about funneling their resources into him
it also comes from their great team
fighting from their top laner zoom
who is the best team fighting top laner
in the league full stop
jdg finished second in the regular
season only behind ig
but in the playoffs they went on a tear
kanavi led them to victory sweeping the
defending world champions fun plus
phoenix before facing off against their
rivals
top esports in the finals it was a
historic moment
for the league china's old guard had
been overthrown by two midlaners who
turned each other into warriors
by a jungler who was hungry to prove
that he was more than just a victim
by a new generation of players desperate
for their shot
at the prize and it was a hell of a show
knight has package jdg it's a numbers
advantage
but top b sports individual players with
the old
again every single time i cast this
champion
he pops off onto the dragon they begin
top b sports are looking to contest this
direct line doesn't connect nor does the
death sentence the dragon
oh caster where did you come from the
soul secured
the fight back to front is there knight
city
six engaged not to find the knock up but
on to the back line they will get the
lockdown on jacket off the death
sentence there
the play is well the fight turning
around kenavi's still alive
even though seoul goes down the lockdown
on
jackie love was beautiful and blue mouth
thrash man
it never ceases to amaze all they have
to do
is hit the nexus and they've done it the
new kings of the lpl
all hail jdg your 2023
champions kanavi came to china on the
worst possible terms
but a year later he ruled the lpl
oh
no
but on the other side of that dramatic
game five
top esports also had a bumpy ride to the
peak of the lpl
they too had faced defeat in the 2019
gauntlet
they too were eliminated by ig in a five
game series
and knight the best player not to go to
worlds
was forced to watch the tournament from
the sidelines
you can see devastation for top esports
they tried their best they put their
heart and soul
into this series and unfortunately it
just wasn't good enough
but 2020 didn't start off too smoothly
for tom
they put together a respectable record
in the weeks after the lpl returned from
the pandemic-induced hiatus
but by the end of week five they were in
fourth
which brings us to the fourth member of
our crew fourth place
wasn't what top wanted they wanted more
so they made a huge shift in the bottom
lane
and changed everything
jackie love was a world champion addy
carrie
but during the offseason he left ig
which made him the hottest free agent
in china but when the season started in
january
jackie love was still teamless and when
the league went on break due to the
pandemic
he was home quarantined in the hubei
province near the virus's outbreak
and even by the time the lpl came back
jackie loves still
didn't have a team but in early april
jackie love finally found a home
on top and then he got to work
vol's to have to flash away grabs from
there now the ability assault comes
through
before the pop blossom has the time with
shaohan as well
nicely done just what we remember as b5
run into him
he's gonna pick up a triple kill jackie
[Music]
[Applause]
i think jackie loves impact has two
dimensions
the obvious one that everyone talks
about is his shot calling but i also
think it gave them a real
like reset a start over because
even knight in carsa who had a terrible
mid jungle 2v2 in spring
it improved so much when jackie love
joined and it probably
gave these guys enough room to refocus
realign and really get on the same page
with how they wanted to play the game
with jackie loving the bot lane and
night at mid top looked like they'd
reached their final form
and they were terrifying oh bp gun
you don't survive this on pb god that's
a big scary snake and you know what
knight is gonna be in a 1v3 here
but i'm thinking i might even favor
knight for this one stunned up
and there's the ulti as well he doesn't
quite have the damage to bring down the
bet yes he does and he's got a lifesteal
to boot as well oh no
no way night you monster
but to truly call 2020 a new era for
this lpl
heist to work they need more than just
jdg
and top and that's where sooning gaming
comes in
sooning's spring 2020 roster was packed
with young
promising talent but it didn't quite
work out
they bombed out of the season with a 7-9
record and didn't even make playoffs
but by the summer split they found their
mojo
all been found by sofon who's just gonna
try and run down the zoe in the meantime
wayway
has just been obliterated on the front
line flash forward the arrow goes wide
but sandy's still gonna be stunned up
using the cleanse to try and get away
from the play kind of barrage to kite
this one out but more goes down
to sofm in the end and it looks like v5
have fallen
and sooning are gonna even up the series
they had an aggressive play style that
mirrored tops with solo lanes that could
go toe-to-toe with the best
and even though top swept them out of
the semi-finals they did the same to lgd
and then did it again in the gauntlet
securing china's third ticket to worlds
with suning just behind them jdg and top
faced off in a summer finals
that felt like fate and when they
stepped on stage to determine
who would get the second title of the
year it truly felt like we were in a new
era the players who had rewritten
history who had circled each other all
year
creating the new great rivalry for the
region
faced off in a historic grand final
and once again they gave us a hell
of a show four shot isn't quite enough
in fact it doesn't come out at all hook
knows why
you can't try to turn this one around
what was that beautiful play out of your
gal as he turns it into more
you yanjo will fall and jakow's showing
us his loose [ __ ]
esports they don't know what's going on
just yet they're going to re-engage onto
lumo he's got himself a stone plate but
he's just not tanky enough goes down but
he's straight up jaguar now loki's
trying to dish out the damage
knight goes into the back line and
absolutely bursts them down we have our
answers it's you yunji now on the plate
yagao versus the world as we see zoom
just
buying time for his mid laner the damage
going on through
three six ninety yu yunja so damn low
and yagao gets the kill
there's only one nexus turret remaining
and top esports will destroy it
the old guard had fallen in a new era
begins in the lpl
after years of denial the second place
was no longer good enough
and top esports are your lpl
2020 champions knight's first domestic
title was a powerful statement for both
him
and his team they entered the world's
group stage as china's strongest team
and for many analysts favorites to lift
the summoner's cup
but roaring into worlds next to them are
two hungry teams who have never made it
to worlds before either
and they want to lift that same trophy
even lgd
china's fourth and final team at worlds
made it in with a revamped roster
one that looks nothing like their old
squads jdg
top and suning all came into the most
chaotic year league of legends had ever
seen with a chip on their shoulders
with something to prove with players who
had spent years
waiting in the shadows overlooked under
appreciated
but ready and they pulled it off they
showed everyone why china is league's
most competitive region
and if they get their way china's
stranglehold over international league
isn't ending anytime soon league of
legends has new kings in a new court
and now there's only one thing left for
them to take
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages